Les États-Unis partagent la 15e place en lecture,
mais nous sommes 23e en sciences et 31e en maths.
Il n'y a qu'un seul domaine où nous sommes proches du sommet
et c'est celui de l'incapacité à donner à nos enseignants
l'aide dont ils ont besoin pour développer leur compétences.
Jetons un coup d’œil au meilleur compétiteur académique :
la province de Shanghai, en Chine.
Ils sont premiers dans toutes les catégories,
lecture, maths et science,
et l'une des clefs du succès incroyable de Shanghai
est leur manière d'aider leurs enseignants à progresser continuellement.
Ils se sont assurés de donner aux jeunes enseignants
une opportunité de voir les maîtres formateurs à l’œuvre.
Ils ont des réunions hebdomadaires
où les professeurs se rassemblent et parlent de ce qui marche.
Ils exigent même que chaque professeur observe
et donne un retour à ses collègues.
Pourquoi un système pareil est-il si important, me direz-vous?
C'est parce qu'il y a tellement de variations
dans l'enseignement.
Certains enseignants sont bien plus efficaces que d'autres.
En fait, il y a des enseignants partout dans le pays
qui aident leurs élèves à faire des progrès extraordinaires.
Si le professeur moyen d'aujourd'hui
pouvait devenir aussi bon que ces professeurs-là,
nos élèves pourraient surclasser la planète entière.
Il nous faut donc un système qui aide nos enseignants à
être aussi bons que les meilleurs.
A quoi ressemblerait ce système ?
Eh bien, pour le savoir, notre fondation
a travaillé avec 3 000 enseignants
dans des quartiers dans tout le pays
sur un projet appelé Mesures d'Enseignement Efficace (MET)
Nos observateurs regardaient des vidéos
d'enseignants en la salle de classe
et les notaient sur une palette de pratiques.
Par exemple, est-ce qu'ils posaient
des questions stimulantes aux étudiants ?
Trouvaient-ils plusieurs manières d'expliquer une idée ?
On soumettait aussi les élèves à des sondages avec des questions telles que,
« Est-ce le professeur reconnaît
quand sa classe a compris un cours ? »
« Apprenez-vous à corriger vos erreurs ? »
Et ce que nous avons trouvé est très enthousiasmant.
Tout d'abord, les enseignants qui répondaient bien à ces attentes
tiraient de bien meilleurs résultats de leurs élèves.
Ça nous dit que nous avons posé les bonnes questions.
Ensuite, les professeurs impliqués dans notre programme nous ont expliqué
que ces vidéos et ces sondages d'élèves
étaient des outils de diagnostique très utiles,
parce qu'ils mettaient le doigt sur des points spécifiques
à partir desquels ils pouvaient s'améliorer.
je veux vous montrer à quoi ressemble
cette vidéo du MET, une fois en action
(Musique)
(Video) Sarah Brown Wessling : Bonjour tout le monde.
Parlons de ce que nous allons faire aujourd'hui.
Pour commencer, on va faire une journée examen entre pairs, d'accord ?
Une journée d'évaluation, et notre but, c'est qu'à la fin du cours
vous soyez capables de déterminer
si vous pouvez vous améliorer dans vos devoirs.
Je m'appelle Sarah Brown Wessling.
J'enseigne l'Anglais au lycée
à la Johnston High School à Johnston, dans l'Iowa.
Tournez-vous vers un de vos voisins.
Dites-lui ce que vous comprenez quand je parle de faire ses preuves. J'ai parlé de --
Je pense qu'il y a une différence pour les professeurs
entre la perception abstraite de notre propre métier
et sa réalité concrète.
Ok, j'aimerais que vous fassiez remonter vos copies, s'il vous plaît
Je pense que cette vidéo nous apporte
un certain degré de réalité.
On ne peut pas vraiment contester ce que l'on voit sur la vidéo,
et il y a beaucoup à en tirer,
et il y a beaucoup de manières de croître
en tant que profession quand on arrive à voir ça.
J'ai seulement un caméscope Flip et un petit trépied
et j'ai investi dans ce tout petit objectif grand angle.
Au début du cours, je n'ai qu'à la percher
au fond de la classe. Ce n'est pas l'angle idéal.
Ça ne capture pas tous les petits détails.
Mais j'ai le son. Je peux voir pas mal de choses,
et je peux en tirer beaucoup.
Ça a vraiment été un outil simple
mais puissant dans mon raisonnement.
D'accord, jetons d'abord un coup d’œil à la plus longue, ok ?
Quand j'ai fini d'enregistrer, je la mets sur l'ordinateur,
et je vais la visionner et la fouiller.
Si je n'écris rien, je les oublie.
Alors avoir mes notes fait partie de mon processus intellectuel
et je découvre les choses au fur et à mesure que je les écris.
J'ai vraiment utilisé ça pour mon propre enrichissement personnel
et ma propre réflexion autour des stratégies d'enseignement
la méthodologie, la gestion des classes
et tous ces aspects différents de la vie de classe.
Je suis contente que l'on ai déjà appliqué ce procédé auparavant
pour pouvoir comparer, en quelque sorte, ce qui marche et ce qui ne marche pas.
Je pense que la vidéo expose tellement d'éléments
qui nous sont intrinsèques en tant qu'enseignants
d'une manière qui nous aide à apprendre, et à comprendre
pour ensuite aider des communautés plus vastes
à comprendre les enjeux de ce travail complexe.
Je pense que c'est une manière d'illustrer
des choses que nous ne pouvons pas véhiculer dans un plan de cours,
des choses qu'on ne peut pas véhiculer via une norme,
des choses qu'on ne peut parfois même pas véhiculer
dans un manuel de pédagogie.
D'accord, tout le monde, passez un bon weekend.
A la prochaine.
[Toutes les classes pourraient ressembler à ça]
(Applaudissements)
Bill Gates : Nous voudrions qu'un jour, en Amérique, chaque salle de classe
ressemble à quelque chose comme ça.
Mais on a encore du travail.
Poser un diagnostic sur les points à améliorer
n'est que la moité du combat.
Nous devons aussi leur donner les outils nécessaires
pour agir sur ce diagnostic.
Si on vous apprend que vous devez améliorer
la manière dont vous enseignez les fractions,
vous devriez avoir accès à une vidéo
montrant la meilleure personne au monde en train de le faire.
Alors, construire ce feedback complet pour les professeurs
et ce système d'amélioration ne sera pas facile.
Par exemple, je sais que certains professeurs
ne sont pas vraiment à l'aise avec l'idée
d'une caméra dans la salle de classe.
C'est compréhensible, mais notre expérience avec MET
suggère que si les enseignants gèrent ce procédé,
s'ils tournent des vidéos dans leur salles de classe,
et qu'ils choisissent les cours qu'ils veulent publier,
beaucoup d'entre eux seront motivés pour participer.
Construire ce système nécessite aussi
un investissement considérable.
Notre fondation estime que ça pourrait coûter
jusqu'à 5 milliards de dollars.
Eh bien, c'est un gros chiffre, mais si on le met perspective,
c'est moins de 2%
de nos dépenses annuelles en salaires d'enseignants.
Les bénéfices pour les enseignants seraient phénoménaux.
On aurait enfin le moyen de leur donner un feedback,
aussi bien que les moyens d'en faire quelque chose.
Mais ce système comporterait
un bénéfice encore plus important pour notre pays.
Il nous mettrait sur une voie qui permettrait
de s'assurer que tous nos élèves bénéficient d'une superbe éducation,
trouvent une carrière épanouissante et gratifiante,
et ont l'opportunité de vivre leur rêves.
On ne ferait pas qu'améliorer la réussite de notre pays,
mais on deviendrait, aussi, un pays plus juste.
Je suis enthousiaste à l'idée
de pouvoir donner à nos enseignants le soutien qu'ils veulent et qu'ils méritent.
J'espère que vous l'êtes aussi.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)